we're being bed and I'll say you know
you really did treat me like a wife
today did I and I'm like yeah and he
goes okay sorry sorry
because it's like hey listen I want to
do everything for you yeah you know I
want to I want to make your life better
I want to serve you the best that I can
like I do our children and like our
friends yeah but do not treat me like
your wife you can treat me like your
girlfriend
and we'll be fine I believe that each
and every one of us has the power within
ourselves to create the life that we
really want and I want to help give you
the tools to make that happen
I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense on the show today is the
beautiful Gabby Reece I have had the
fortune of getting to know Gabby on a
personal level she of course was very
famous volleyball player and now she is
a fitness guru she is obviously wife to
Laird Hamilton they have incredible
health food companies that are helping
people every single day get away from
things that are not helping their body
but I really know her on the fitness
level and as time is going on more and
more on a mental level where I just
relate to her so much I think that we
have similar backgrounds of being female
athletes and also purely just being
athletes and the mindset that you need
to have to succeed in your sport which
really translates to in this world so we
work out together she recently took me
to a pool workout at her house where I
I'm pretty fit I mean I'm not gonna lie
but there was some stuff I just
literally couldn't do and I've realized
holding my breath is one of them so
she's really pushing me to stretch
beyond my comfort zone into areas that
I've never touched before and I'm very
inspired by that I'm also inspired by
her being so into wanting relationships
to be good she works really hard on her
personal relationships her marriage the
relationships with her kids and she
learned some really valuable things
growing up about how to do that and the
fact that she was never told that she
had to be somebody when she grew up so
we talked about how that is now
affecting her life as a mom trying to
send that same message so I really hope
you enjoyed today's episode well I I
finally decided to say yes to the pool
workout because we were doing this
interview today it kind of I mean there
was like a couple other opportunities I
probably could have done it but I
thought this will be a really good thing
to experience to understand a little bit
more of the scope of what you do with
workouts and you know what you've done
so much you know your belief and your
the importance of breathing because lord
knows even at the workouts with weights
that we do when we do some breathing
afterwards and you tell me to hold my
breath for 90 seconds I mean I'm laying
there going 48 49 I can't do it so it's
really hard for me so I know I need to
do more of it but that was crazy and it
was really unique and different which
we're gonna get into but first and
foremost like you do free workouts every
day with people and I'm just I'm trying
to understand like how did that start
because every day means every day about
Sunday right right hmm what is it Monday
Wednesday Friday is in the gym and then
Tuesday Thursday Saturday is in the pool
and there's anywhere from you know 22 in
Hawaii like a hundred people yeah so
what started that I well it's it's sort
of twofold when I learned this from
kawaii and we lived on Maui for a really
long time and when we we moved back to
Hawaii they shut the gym and so I had I
could use the hotel's gym I was allowed
to use it and I thought oh well I could
probably take my quit I had a bunch of
equipment and I thought I told like six
or seven of the girls that I was
acquaintance with maybe two close
friends but pretty much you know
acquaintances I said you know what I
could rent out the community center
three days a week for an hour
then you guys can join me and we'll
train together and also that's a
built-in accountability for me let's not
you know kid ourselves and think of some
Pollyanna like oh and you're pretty
Polly or no but it's it's also being
clear that I can go down the rabbit hole
on work emails and other things and so I
had to show up to and before you knew it
it turned into 30 and then 40 and then
you know on average it was about 60 to
80 people what I did charge everyone a
dollar though because they weren't so
they could be under my insurance ah you
know so we have a contract right that's
not a fee that's being extra nice that's
a little above and beyond nice you know
a couple things happened is it was a
classroom for me and a way to you know
keep learning and a reason to keep
learning cuz he had to show up and sort
of like could you be do it better could
you be better could you add exercises or
something like that and then the other
side of that was when I was in town I
you know I could do it and I always told
them this is not a democracy it's a
dictatorship so also it was done in a
way that was very comfortable for me I
didn't have to deal with people's stuff
yeah cuz I'm not you know that's not
really my thing and stuff you know it's
like if you're an instructor and you're
a paid instructor then you're beholden
to everyone's whims and opinions and I
just shut all that down that was pretty
clear at the top so I also had the
opportunity to construct it the way that
it would work well for me and so and
listen it's a small place you know what
it's like to live in a small town and so
it was my community service so to speak
because it was a way to give without
actually having to get overly entangled
so I could be at the grocery store and
see people and just like hey and they're
like that Gabby so great because I was
get doing my community service and I and
that's important to me it's really
important and and then Anne in Malibu I
do it for my girlfriends there and part
of that joke was how if you if they pay
you
that's even worse cuz then those girls
like oh I'm so sorry I'm an hour late
you know it's like it's true yeah it's a
bad business yeah and each any business
that takes just your real hours you know
you
over the years like you have to have a
business that makes money when you're
asleep not like your real hours I've
done that yeah that's right and so this
is a way the way it moves was I can
still be friends with them they can't
get distracted they can't talk because
they will you know I might have been the
one talking this week when we started on
it like and then you said something I
basically just felt like it was for me
and I was like totally respect that I
better shut up I don't think it was but
it's good so I think that's how it
started and and you know it's just a
really easy way to give to my friends in
a way that feels good to me and I have
to show up and do it and I think it just
works out so I'm listen I'm sure I'm
giving up my time but I don't think I'm
you know I'm stretching you feel like
you would do a lot less if you didn't
have that accountability or do you think
you'd I mean I can't picture you doing a
lot less I don't you know I'm not I
don't know that I'm like you in this way
of like there you have this I'm very
self driven you have another level of
being self driven and also I am at the
tail end of parenting three daughters
and I am 12 or more years older than you
are and so I think you also get to a
place where your your type I'm a look I
can be tired so now I'm like okay I have
to create an environment that I can be
successful not I'm just gonna muscle
through everything so I think it's also
me being very clear about where I could
fall off certainly I'm very disciplined
yeah and and your type a and and self
driven but life when they say you know
life gets in the way life can get in the
way you know this pickup or drop-off
this meeting you know whatever it is can
get in the way so I I have a you know
again it's I always tell people listen
it's not about flying out of bed each
day so excited to be punished and punish
yourself it's about creating a system
yeah that you know you can be successful
yeah it's that punishing I think is like
the bad reputation right like if the
punishment is like I gotta go work out
yeah it's not a punishment it feels
amazing it's really fun and you create
friendships as you know you have a
hundred people showing up for your
workout they like you you
extremely likeable and you get I don't
think good commission they might not
like you when you have to do like the
six hop knee up on the seventh
side-to-side for a minute or like
pulsing lunges with the weights in your
hands and you bud is on fire but they
love you overall for your you know
kindness and your determination but I
feel like working out and even eating
right has this like negative connotation
like it's a punishment to you and really
it's more about the ability to be able
to you know to be able to go move to be
able to go do those things to be able to
to maintain that and have fun and create
the relationships and friendships and I
just think there's like it's just a bad
rap that working out has well okay the
other side of that could be you started
in your life of discipline and and a
work ethic very early so your work
capacity and also the way your brain is
hardwired naturally and magnified by
your lifestyle and you felt the feeling
of how good it feels so many times that
you're sold you have people that don't
feel well they're overwhelmed by their
lives yeah and their relationships maybe
they don't love their job I mean you got
to drive real fast around or do
something pretty cool and so I think
sometimes it's just being aware that not
you just me being aware that and I came
through sport and so a lot of people
haven't touched that feeling of like how
powerful it can be in your life so it's
really about getting them to go okay if
you don't love it can we get you to love
the people you're gonna train with or
can we get you to do it long enough that
at least you put effort into finding out
what you don't hate to roof right yeah
so if I do something you enjoy doing
enough to keep doing it or like today
I've loved the fact that our friend
Emily is petrified of Kult achieve no
real quick I had no real fear when she
said in the the truth the truth barrel
which is 220 degrees it was 220 today
and you sit in there and cook or cook
the workout as Laird would call it we're
sitting in there and she said she would
rather
go in a shark shark-infested water then
go in cold water I was like oh this
girl's really scared but Emily went in
the water and she did it and she like I
don't know if he saw she posted an
Instagram I'm sure and they cook it's
like super long it's basically like a
confessional and like a you know just
the pouring of joy and she said she's on
a high and that is something to get used
to - like you know overcoming fear for a
second or getting to the point where
you're uncomfortable but you know
pushing through right like you like you
say to us when we're working out like
can you stay with me for another if it's
if it's holding your breath another five
zero seconds I'm like that's 50 just say
it's 50 you're like eight seconds come
on let's go and you know it's that you
know that feeling that you get
afterwards because there's no you know
to get a reward you have to go through a
little bit of pain or a little bit of
discomfort in order to feel some kind of
reward other than otherwise you're just
walking and talking and just going about
your normal day and I think that that's
something that people I feel like maybe
that's something that I was I practiced
doing in my entire life was was bumping
into discomfort because that's what
driving was it was like I wasn't
comfortable crashing I wasn't
comfortable sliding but I had to get I
had to continuously bump up against my
comfort zone sure every freaking lap
yeah that was my job yeah and I don't
even like that job but that became
really something that I you know got
comfortable with right get find comfort
in the discomfort yeah and I think I
think you know we live in a world where
where everything's comfortable right we
have air conditioning we have heat and
we drive places and and food is readily
available and things like that so I
think the other side of that is when you
get we talked about this earlier when
you can provide healthy opportunities
and that just means non self-destructive
to meet yourself and to say oh okay
there I am and meet your character and
do things that make you uncomfortable
because then we're expanding still yeah
right instead of well I don't do that
because I'm this age or
you know all of these limitations and I
think that you have to you know create
that tension positive tension so that
you can continue to expand and grow and
and and for me you know life is a
forward moving process versus well you
know back then that was pretty great and
I really enjoyed that back there
I'm still trying to continue to look
forward to things and to be comfortable
with with that I use someone who what
how do you answer if I said if you could
go back and change anything in your life
what would you change well I mean you
know I could give you the Pat answer of
like oh well I would change nothing and
I wouldn't be here as I am today listen
there's some things I've gone through as
a parent that have been pretty
uncomfortable and even those I wouldn't
change I would say I would have
stretched more that's it just stretch
your body you mean absolutely because I
think I I missed an opportunity to avoid
injuries by having better range safer
range of motion and things like that but
I realize that's a fairly small I wish I
would have right like this isn't like
man I wish I wouldn't have you know
married that guy I wish I would have
taken that wish I wouldn't have moved
here I wish I had enough I wish I are a
little bigger stretching I think we can
say that's a fairly small like man if I
could look back and just like maybe pull
anything out of it I just say maybe more
stretching yeah and I think listen when
I was competing I wish I wasn't so
concerned about pleasing everyone yeah I
think I if you asked me something if I
could have approached it differently
as a 20 and early 30-something woman you
know there was a part of me that was
apologetic for attention and for other
things that did have especially when you
play team sports so there was something
uncomfortable about that and I think in
a way you sort of think oh I wasn't as
robust as I could have been as an
athlete as an outspoken person and
things like that so I mean on another on
a deeper level I think that's something
but I think we don't get to know that
until we actually get to go through that
yeah
that's part of the process right if
you'd have just known that then it would
all been easy and there would no room
for growth yeah and maybe you know it's
like I had I know a few female athletes
that you know had a few older brothers
and they got to that real quick cuz they
just knew it wasn't personal and I think
for other women I mean it feels to me
that you have the opportunity to sort of
Teeter in between where for me it took
me a little bit longer to be like yeah
okay you're you are upset about
something about me or something I've
done or you think something about the
way it's going for me is unfair and I
don't need to show you like I'm a good
person by trying to manage how you're
feeling and I think that takes a minute
to in everything right in business in
personal relationships
why did you feel like you had to justify
yourself why should I guilty well I've
said this a few times I wasn't really
groomed for success you know Laird nor
myself grew up in environments where
because there's a you I sort of have to
learn that I think that the disservice
parents do is when they over inflate to
their children like how great you are
but I think there is something to be
said for saying it's okay to win it's
okay to expect to win when you go out
and do whatever endeavor you're doing
you don't have to apologize to win you
don't have to feel like that makes you
not a nice person because you know also
in volleyball right your opponent's
right here like right there and so it's
like okay like if the goal is to win
we'll just then go ahead and crush them
but when you're growing up I get on her
head
yeah and it's but that doesn't make you
bad a ton you know a bad / you know
serve bad so I think it took me on
really long time and also if you've
grown up a certain way and then all of a
sudden you think oh I want to build a
different kind of life right
that takes getting used to what that
looks like and what feels comfortable to
who you really are and not in an
overcompensation way yeah right so it's
it's I think it's all of that yeah what
do you feel like was the first thing
that popped up for you where you're like
man I'm gonna have to get over this oh
my goodness well I mean listen
you have to do is add kids to any
formula and you have no time to mess
around without those ideas and also you
go through enough things where you
realize you can't please anymore
everyone anyway right 100% and if you do
then you're probably pretty damn boring
well you just but you can't write like
you're on the fence I had a coach Tom my
college coach we were discussing her
earlier and she said to me something
really powerful that I probably caught
on to ten years after the fact she said
like when she coaches she's got 12
athletes six play all the time eight are
playing regularly right so she goes that
means at least I have six to four people
four to six people that are unhappy or
pissed off and she says I have a job to
do and my job is to look what's the
greatest combination for the goal and
she goes and then at least at the end of
the day I know one person is happy and
she said me and I think for me what I've
learned is I have to listen to myself
and I have to trust that and let the
chips you know are you a people pleaser
like are you no I wouldn't say it's that
it's trying to be hyper conscientious
that you're not to do things a lot of
empathy I mean I feel like I'm yes and
no like in certain ways not at all right
like in certain ways everything is
through my cranium and it's but it's
also being sensitive to if you're
fortunate if you've been given
opportunity that's surpassed yes and I
think it's not about you know so you're
always kind of checking to make sure
that you're clear about that you're
living by the values that you have and
that you're honoring like someone handed
you the baton for a minute yeah and
other people have the baton and the my
baton has moved around but I think it's
it's more of me checking in on myself
because at the end when I brush my teeth
I just need to make sure that I'm clear
and comfortable with the way I'm
behaving and it's certainly gotten
easier as I'm older it's like yeah okay
I can't I can't get out tap dance
anymore you know yeah I'm not gonna put
myself through that I'm sorry like whoa
so it's
according to fitness like when I go work
out with people mm-hmm I love making up
workouts right like I mean I love her
and you make them up during your coffee
which is like what I do too
so I think one of the hardest things for
people because I really believe Fitness
is a way to grow confidence and to be
empowered and that just seeps into your
life everywhere it can help you grow and
be brave enough to stand in who you
really are and what you want and face
challenging things how did you learn I
mean how did you learn how most people
never learn how to even work out like I
I'm a judge er of the junior super judge
opinions I died no way especially in the
gym and it's like but I actually have
learned to feel a little bit more
sympathy and understanding that when I
see somebody on the elliptical they pry
don't know what else to do yeah you know
when I see somebody doing half of a
pushup
I'm like they probably don't really know
what to do yeah and you know I that but
I don't think there's a lot of education
I mean aren't they even going I think
even doing away with some physical
fitness and school and stuff I mean I
feel like people can't afford a thing
yeah they can't afford it she's just
crazy cuz look doing a pull-up could
save your life right you fall off a
cliff yeah well they say right push up
and pull up is two of the greatest real
strength to building you have to if you
can't do them that I mean literally one
of those could save your life where I'm
pretty sure knowing geometry is not
gonna save my life
worried where are you hanging out Tanika
your leg all falling off mountains yeah
I'm not super brave so are your hikes
risky or what yeah you know what it's
saving my dog let me get out onto an
edge oh my gosh shoot get back here now
and then I have to tiptoe out there and
there Billy Goats and I'm like I'm
scared no get over here if I fall I can
do a pull-up though but how did you
how'd you even learn how well you know
listen coming from professional sports I
and being in California you I've had the
luxury of having access to some of the
best movement people yeah out there so
for trainers yes and then you know just
out of necessity like when the class
developed it was like oh okay I got to
figure this out and then you know we
have one of the businesses we have
X be brave you realize that right like
you're like I'm gonna have a class oh
god I got to make up a workout like they
can't even make it up for themselves if
they do it at home yeah but sooner sit
there it's not that brave
I think listen if you say then you think
I don't I'm more ambitious than you
think maybe then I think if you pay
attention in life and especially when
you're exposed to environments I think
you the opportunity to pick things up is
pretty real if you're really paying
attention and and I think the
willingness to say I may not be perfect
but I'm really going to give it
everything I have
that usually kind of makes things work
out well I think that that amount of
humility resonates with people right if
you said they're like you give it up on
the front end and say like okay mine I'd
be perfect today or like oh I'm sorry I
forgot this you know forgot this station
you know right that like people that
makes you approachable well okay so
here's what I know about teaching
especially big classes is I'm not there
to show you that I can dominate you I'm
there to create an environment for you
to get a good workout in and so one part
of that is I have another side of my
personality and a character that's like
nope let's not screw around why so that
the environment is set that there's
order you need order in order to execute
everything and so there's one side where
I'm like I'm not here to dominate you or
make it impossible for you and the way
I'm going to show you how much I care
about you and love you is I'm going to
keep order so that you leave with having
success and that means if anyone
threatens that order they will have a
they will hear it from me yeah and very
quickly and so there's it's sort of
twofold where there's a part of me
that's like you know I have kicked
people out of class the joke is I have
two close friends that I'm like if you
continue to talk I'll kick you out and
and they look at me and these are my
friends yeah and in that moment I'm like
yeah no try me because what they're
doing you're not paying and there's
order well and we have 15 other people
or 50 other people
it's not about you and it's not about me
we're all gonna play by the rules and do
it so I think within it it's like an
interesting thing what do they say being
charged on in control all right I'm not
here to control everybody I'm just here
to be in charge that's where I suffer
what do you mean you want to control
everything because when I see them just
doing a poor movement I'm like oh my god
yeah just do it if you hadn't handled us
through it a few more years okay and
you'll get tenderized by that whole
thing I found that one of the things if
because I've really only taught a few
classes yeah workouts which I had a good
time but I am a drill sergeant I sure am
I see that about I I love that about you
that's what when you walked in the first
day to the workout when I my first day I
was like I love her already
because you're very strong and let's not
mess around we're here to work out we're
not here to hang out right and but I
think that one of the most difficult
things other than trying to get everyone
to do everything properly is just to
make sure no one gets hurt that's it
that's that's the key and also you have
to realize half of them are are more
successful and even have accomplished
beyond what you could want for them in a
perfect push-up the fact that they're
there yeah and I think it's yeah
recognizing that and then slowly you go
hey let's watch that and hang watch that
and they start to put it together and by
the way there's some people who never
put it together I have people in my
quiet class for eight years I'm like
still doing that move huh pretty good
okay and you just realized sanera squad
not a forward fold
it's just okay it's the way it is and
also again I that's another thing about
maturity for me is everybody has their
way mm-hmm what what about you and Laird
working out together yeah not so much
I'm asking for tips because they're a
little work out with me much I'll be in
the pool Dillard and I work out because
we're underwater so there's a lot of
talking and they're sort of like pockets
of working out there I think there's
music underwater
when you do a long hole it's like back
and forth back and forth six times or
whatever sometimes you're like just
listen to the music I think by the way I
just so people get some perspective back
and forth six times I do back then I go
forth and each time I take a breath and
you're saying you go back and forth
without taking a breath so that's just
your I'm doing one you're doing six and
I've been doing it for 11 years so it
was you've done it once I know you have
these stanzas have a reference for how
good you are at it
I'm just experienced okay look I am
experienced and I have some comfort in
the water but I say you just look at
each other underwater and dance and just
like over next move but you know both
Laird and I are very bossy people in our
own ways and so what I do what in our
training life we use each other as
confidants and and sort of like if I'm
thinking about something or I'll use him
because he I really respect his opinion
about the about movement and Laird is
I'm very linear and he's very very
creative and so it's an it's a very nice
balance and also his relationship I have
a good relationship with discomfort his
relationship with discomfort is like I I
can't keep up with that it's like a best
friend he just he just he's you know
listen he's hard wired I've seen a lot
of athletes very very good athletes some
of the best in the world and maybe two
or three guys like Laird where their
ability to manage that is pretty I mean
he you know his sport probably helped
with that getting his brain dialed into
a level of intensity and seriousness
that the repercussions are are pretty
serious so like what oh well I mean if
you write if you surf a wave that is 80
feet tall if you wipe out or you don't
make the right choices I don't know if
the white water on a wave like that is a
35 feet well it's a three-story building
and that's the white water what does
that mean so when the wave breaks and
then you have like this foam so you know
when you go to the beach and the little
wave breaks and here comes the white
water that's like by your ankles yeah
well
is 35 feet geez and so you're just
talking about a different environment
yeah you know people who do things in a
you know mountain climbers or
you know but at least the mountains
fixed you know even for Aaron like you
have guys who want to rip your head off
your your brain is working differently
and so I like to train with layer but
I'm trying to be married to layered as a
husband and wife and not to be
competitive that way
it's I mean like what's it like what's
it because you we both are and I think
that you know
similarly with Aaron and I you know both
being athletes we we both are too and I
got very soft danica you do bear you're
the one that softens well Laird is very
loving and attentive you know he's a
person who's what like I feel very
cherished by Laird but I don't direct
Laird I mean I sort of encourage Laird
and sort of you know finesse things but
I don't usually come at him very hard
unless it's first a real reason and that
maybe once or twice a year and when I do
it story of one of those times uh well
no I mean you have to remember too we
work together sometimes there's a
business-oriented then it's more about
the way I get spoken to so if I'm
managing a hundred details and you're
frustrated about some commitment I'll
let it go for a while because what I
what I love about him is because he is
sort of this artist he really is and he
neat you have to realize if you were
gonna race you knew the day and the time
he's waiting for something so there's
part of week there was a big waves and
future three day notice three day notice
and he goes to meet this well once the
conditions all sort of say yes it's all
working the waiting in this well but
think about it like being on call being
on calm being ready and the other side
of it is so there's a part of him that
wants to feel like at any moment I have
the freedom to go right we have
commitments like months and months out
right and that's hard on him and
I love about him is his the way he has a
he's the most disciplined person I know
but within that two he's also very very
free and wild and as his partner I don't
want that to go away right because what
makes him right correct right then I'm
like oh I get it it's connected to all
that great stuff I love but after a
while if it gets taken out on me it's
kind of like this it's like like any
relationship I think people can have bad
moods bad days and I always said if you
could make me feel like I was inside the
bubble and not take it out on me or
alienate me because you're going through
that I'm not gonna hassle you I'm not
gonna tell you to feel different just
respect me don't direct it at me and
also I allow me to be inside it's when
people shut down isolate and push you
out so totally agree and that didn't
happen in the first three years of our
relationship that's a male thing I think
it's I think it's more male than female
but if you have a competitive person or
an intense person or maybe a person who
lives in their in their mind their
tendency is to go inside right and so I
think it's just understanding how to
dance during those times yeah and also
be reminded all the time and I do this
in parenting there are some traits about
my children that are very challenging
and it is exactly the same thing that
will make them dynamic interesting sure
you already have it right don't you hate
you love to for certain reasons was this
something in the beginning that you
would force you to feel insecure like no
I'm not insecure I think just pissed and
and you know the are the first five
years of our relationship you know we
had a we have had and still have a
pretty magnetic draw to one another but
after about five years I was very I got
sort of tired because I'm very even
killed so I got very tired or resentful
of Laird's moodiness however I didn't
speak up so the thing I learned after
you know we had our challenges
earlier in our relationship was it was
better to have one really uncomfortable
conversation or healthy conflict than to
just go well I love him so I'll sweep it
under the carpet right and Laird is very
good about clearing the decks like every
day like we go to bed that our
relationship is as clear as this table
because you know it's just easier to go
I need to talk about something and they
go what and you go oh this instead of
like oh that and you can't even get to
what is the real issue
sure versus but again a lot of these
things take making mistakes and and
maybe even thinking you're not going to
be together and then sort of saying well
it's worth it so what we're not going to
be miserable so let's work on it let's
make it so that we are separately and
together you know I hate the word
happiness it's not it's in a joyful
place it's in a peaceful place you know
happiness sort of comes in and out and I
I don't even know that happiness is a
sort of a goal of mine I really enjoy
peace and what is then I think peace is
important for me as I heard and of all
raava can't say that happiness was peace
in motion and that you could access at
any time if you had peace and I sort of
really liked that idea
and growth I think learned and I
independently really enjoy you know
trying to expand what have you learned
about yourself in the 21 years a memory
oh my god because it's really about the
self right I mean it's you know instead
of what have you learn about the
relationships really about you right
because they're all different yeah you
or the common denominator yeah you know
without Troy Ralph every time you're
looking outside of yourself to feel good
it's either not gonna happen or be
extremely inconsistent and unpredictable
and not relying you can't rely on that
forever even so what have you learned
about yourself I think I learned that I
I was not raised in a way to rely on
someone else to make me happy and so I
think what's good about Laird
and being with Laird is he's a very
generous
and loving person but I think he feels
the same way it's like we joke you know
like you go and make yourself happy I'll
go make myself happy in them and then we
can be together so I think what I've
learned is that I I think I always felt
that way and I wasn't looking for
someone to rescue me or save me or pay
my bills I was looking for a partner and
and also that I wanted somebody that if
it really came down like if you know it
all hit the fan that someone who could
handle it because I've seen Laird in
action
you know handful of times in our
relationship you mean save your house
from burning down in Malibu exactly
seriously I mean that's right I mean
like I'm a very in a way I hate Lee
really fought the fire I think it's
important there with like hoses buckets
friends like I'm gonna fight this fire
and you know he saved the house yeah and
that's what I'm talking about that's
fantast like I'll deal with the emails
and all the other stuff and if like you
know things happen because I realize
like I was where I was raised in the
Caribbean right so I think I was always
clear about survival and what Laird also
represents to me and the thing I've
learned about myself is that feels
pretty important meaning let's not get
distracted by all the stuff and the
noise and all of the chaos around us
let's be really clear life is pretty
simple you know it's like you need to
eat you need to sleep you want to feel
safe and and you want to have a partner
that you love and that loves you and
things like this and so I think Laird is
a real manifestation of how I really do
even though I like to be challenged and
busy with work and all of these things
that it's pretty simple for me do you
feel like you're kind of mirrors for
each other like you're so similar in
that way that you really are you know to
people that and it sounds it probably
felt selfish or not culturally normal to
be like Oh have a partner and just fall
right into it you just blend into each
other and be like you know somewhere
deep down
you really want to go do your own thing
you know which means you're gonna
respect and see that in a partner too
yeah you know without you he'd be lost
vice versa because you both need that
space but you both want that space so
it's perfect you can see it in each
other yeah and I think you can not take
it personal that the other person has
something they have to go do and Laird
has lifelong love affair with his sport
and I am I think it's
it's such a great quest like for me I'm
like I I support that all the way does
um just the wave always win
Oh his girlfriend mm-hmm I would say
there he never has to make that choice
and I think what it is is that he knows
that and also the wave goes away at
nighttime like Laird was leaving to Fiji
last night and he said I really wish
though like I could have my family with
me so when I come home we are all in the
same you know we're in the bed together
we eat dinner together his family is
very important to him and sometimes
that's not possible to do he did take
one of our daughters but I think it's
not an either/or and he feels
comfortable and you feel comfortable to
say I get that the wave wins but it only
wins because it's temporary I'm always
here well yes and and she comes so
infrequently and also he's he's quite
delightful when he comes home from
surfing and so I'll take it because
otherwise he can get a little bit like a
caged animal
and and so I I just I sort of feel like
people that's why if they can develop
their own passions yeah they won't think
of it as something in conflict with the
love that their partner has for them but
rather something that feeds their
partner and makes them really better
when they come out I think that's a
valuable lesson I think that you know
I've even dealt with my own insecurities
about that like when somebody has
something that that's there you are yeah
I'm actually I don't understand why when
you say that like you you a very defined
person to me I am I mean I am growing
out of it but have been a jealous type
and I broke it actually down to the fact
that if
like just in a conversation with a
friend I realized that my example
growing up of a relationship was
spending 100% of the time together my
parents work together took trips
together Meg's never did anything with
my mom never had girlfriends my dad
never went out with the guys like my
parents were together 100% of the time
and that was my example of a good
relationship and they've done married
since 1980 I'm not good at math so I
like a long time now yeah but that was
what I saw so for me it's really hard to
break that that you can see Otto
tomorrow so but I've always been that
person that's kind of you know either
that or kind of felt like maybe the may
be that outward cry would be that you
know I I like want to be I want to be
there for all the fun too you know
oh you have a little FOMO little FOMO
okay a little bit of FOMO a little bit
of like jealousy of time but it's true
when you go away and do your own thing
like when I've and I've learned this
over time when I go away and do my own
thing and spend time with my girlfriends
or go do something that fills me up
something even that this show has done
that for me
like I come back better for the other
person because I'm energized I'm excited
I'm happy I've been yeah my cup is
filling up in a way that he can't do you
know but it it's only filling up for him
right like at the end of the day for you
um damn and for you right now when our
cups are full for both sides like we're
we don't have as much animosity
resentment jealousy anger boredom
frustration like we're just like having
a good time we're happy right we're
happiness we're where you were peace in
motion yeah and I think life is really
really short and if we can figure out
how to make our relationships rich and
simplified I think it's a it's time it's
an effort well spent because if you
really think about the times that we
spent in conflict about things or even
fretting about things even outside of
our relationship it's - life's too short
and and so
I think also people will be with us
because they want to him if they don't
want to they won't that's actually
something that I have thought so many
times and I think I maybe said it even
before like you know what and it sounds
kind of mean in a way because it seems
really like blunt but I'm like look
you're you still you're still here you
still want to be with me so I need to
realize that it's because you want to of
course instead of look for all the
reasons why I'm not good enough or I'm
not smart enough or funny enough or
pretty enough or ambitious enough or you
know not enough period isn't it funny
though that a person can be have so many
things going for them and like outwardly
right like nevermind okay someone who
lives in a small town and they have a
nice job they're an attorney and they
have a nice job and they're you know all
these things you've lived in a world
you've been on a big stage you've had a
lot of people tell you from your group
to the media about how great you are but
I think it's it's such an important
point that unless we can feel those ways
about us and not in an inflated way it
does really impact so positively the
rest of you know your life your
relationships and you know I always joke
with Laird after I mean literally in
November we'll be together for 24 years
and I'm like you know you're here always
like I always want him to feel like oh
yeah I can go anytime I want
because then he doesn't feel the there's
no pressure about being there it's
understanding like I'm exactly where I
want to be when you look at it like that
if you go there's no pressure to be here
you're free right and that person keeps
coming home to you that means more than
if they feel trapped right now so that's
if you can just like let go of the
control and the wanting of something for
yourself so much yeah and love the
person totally no matter what it is and
they are free to go like they can go do
what they want and go period if they
want and they know that mm-hmm and if
they keep coming back that actually
speaks significant volumes compared to
the other where
like right oh yeah oh hey I'm breaks got
me at home can't go anything I kind of
got a lie to her and say I was yeah I
mean that's that's shitty little there's
much fulfillment in the freedom for
yourself if you can just get there one
you know I'm coming home de Larroque
he's not coming home to me just be clear
about that I'm still coming home to him
why do you say it like that I'm joking
I'm kidding he's not coming home on that
it's all sure no I'm joking but I think
the other side of that too is you know
I've had once in a while if we get a
little bit husband e wifey kind of thing
we'll be in bed and I'll say I'm pretty
matter-of-fact like I'm actually not
emotional and lucky for layered I'm not
so I really take my time to respond to
things especially the heat if they get
heated you know I don't just go you know
I mean you have to really get me good
for me just to go straight is he more
ballistic
oh yeah well he's not ballistic he's
he's interesting he's purely emotional
and sort of intuitive but the heavier
situation gets the more calm Larry gets
right so he but he's all emotional you
know and so um it's the part foot wave
he's looking at he goes oh yeah he slows
it way down right and we're being bed
and I'll say you know you really did
treat me like a wife today
did I and I'm like yeah and he goes okay
sorry sorry because it's like hey listen
I want to do everything for you yeah you
know I want to I want to make your life
better I want to serve you the best that
I can like I do our children and like
our friends yeah but do not treat me
like your wife you can treat me like
your girlfriend and we'll be fine
that's actually great yeah and I don't
say more than that I joined I like that
you know you you kind of treating me
like your wife today and he'll say do
you know so well that's a bad thing then
well it's just it's deleting thank you I
granted it's a little like it's a norm
like you do this either
like little passive that's not so Sparky
and me yeah check joyful it's like it's
like just it is whatever yeah oh my god
so and I don't know I'm just a lawyer
I'm that maybe I should just stay as
girlfriend forever listen it's a idols
and baloney anyway I've seen people who
are in relationships there are married
then married the institutions of the
world are really interesting to me and
and marriage is one of them because you
know look if you got married and you you
know back in the old days before they
had tattoo removal it would be like a
tattoo like it's just there forever yeah
but you know nowadays especially and
even in the past you could still
separate and you could still divorce but
it's so much more normal now it kind of
makes you question the institution when
but you know kids come into the picture
and it kind of makes it interesting
which you know like yeah I mean there's
all there's all parts of points of that
star and I think a lot of as long as the
couples on the same page like a do you
feel good do you feel good
I mean I've heard stories of people who
I have a friend who was together with
her partner for 30 years and I think for
like insurance like as they got older
they decided to get married and this is
a couple so dedicated and committed to
each other they were together but I'm
married for like 30 years
yeah and then they went got married and
she said to me though and this is a this
was like they were completely fine and I
mean like a very beautiful couple like
very loving and she said you know it was
interesting though there was something
interesting about maybe the ceremony
like the notion of we're gonna stand up
and do this and I think everybody's
different I think you know the girls
that have those crazy weddings I for me
personally in the language I speak I'm
like why would you not put it like buy a
house like you don't I mean like when I
see all this like it's the prom adult
prom and then I think okay when it's all
done and they're there you are it's like
all that show and all that build-up and
all that stuff and then in the end
though it's like it's just us yeah -
with a picture of that ceremony that you
can it is just one little moment yeah
and so I think everybody jump one
you know that's what you that's your
memory so I just I think I think it's
whatever works for the people but again
just loving someone and cherishing them
I think if you did you getting that how
did you guys learn how to communicate
because then communication is one of
those things like there had it's just
difficult yeah sure
I think it's trial and error I mean what
we did almost break up that one time and
that lasted off and on for about a year
and then you get to a place where you go
okay so is it worth it to stay together
and and once you decide yes it is I
think this is another thing I find
fascinating with people even in their
regular everyday lifestyle well this
isn't working for me and I don't like
this but yet you know it's the same
behavior over and over I think there
comes a point like in the relationship
were like okay this wasn't totally
working so what do we want to do to
change and it isn't me time Laird this
is how you can change it was me having
to look at myself and say okay I'm not I
wasn't willing to be vulnerable or I was
too afraid to be by yourself first well
that's who I'm responsible for right
Laird is responsible for himself and I
can say hey when this behavior comes out
that makes me uncomfortable like so if
you're acting a certain way sure
or talking to me in a certain way I'm
not comfortable with that ended up
saying don't do that you go when you do
this I don't feel really unimportant or
when you do this I feel offended you
know and it's about how you feel and
they can decide what to do with it and
that's on him yeah you know if he wants
to you know he said like if you if we're
all bringing our best chances are we're
gonna what you can muddle through some
stuff yeah because if the intention is I
don't need to be right I'm just looking
to reach a resolution then you can
really go far there and the intention is
also I'm going to genuinely look at
what's best for you and that person's on
the same page and you know you can get
through a lot of stuff and you and also
when you practice getting through it I
do think it's like you can get through
it faster and faster
you know Laird and I had like the
smallest conflict I came home an hour
later and then I was supposed to be home
and when I walked in he's like oh I
thought you were coming home
an hour ago and I was like first of all
like my instant my reaction is like like
you're not my dad
like I'm a grown-ass woman like you know
my dad like I don't know but I was in
traffic yeah so okay oh that was so fun
yeah whoo an hour late cuz I was in
traffic a little slow okay we got to
dinner and he was being he's Dennis the
Menace a little like he'll kind of poke
and try to get reactions because he's
just a that's him and so sitting at
dinner and he I go so they said
something about the training I oh what'd
you guys do today he said oh yeah we
laid around and I was like oh okay so I
was like and so then after he he started
to pick up on the by race use like
what's up and I go here's the deal when
I walk in and I'm an hour behind don't
question me say hello
get up give me a kiss and when I asked
you how your training was tell me how
your training was like that but I wasn't
freaking out yeah and then he started
laughing and then I of course are
laughing cuz it's so small and then he
goes well okay I'll talk about my
training I go and know it I don't care
anymore that's what you don't understand
like I'm over that hey shot and I don't
think it's so I don't think it's about
being hysterical I don't think it's
about ending that but I think it's about
going like you know I've had to remind
later we have three daughters sometimes
he'll talk to me in that tone and I'll
just look at him and I'll go I just want
to remind you I'm your wife I'm not your
daughter like and that's all I have to
say I don't have to go like and name
Union and it's like you know and and
also being your best I think if I look
to him and I see a guy who's really
trying his best it inspires me and
conversely
sometimes he might have a dip and he's
funky and he's stomping around if I hold
my high line mm-hmm
I find that he will look and see and be
more inspired to come back up right then
if I go you know come back up right and
so I think you know you just learned but
it's what are you being honest about why
you're there and if you need to be in
control of somebody then you should be
at least with somebody who wants to be
controlled because then at least you're
on the same page right there might be
people are like yes please tell me where
to go and what to do and how to act and
they like that you know it's like people
maybe who go hey I want to go to a job
and when the job is done at five o'clock
I want to turn it off and I don't want
to think about it everybody is different
it's all goods okay but line up with
somebody and I am definitely married to
somebody who does not want to be
controlled so how the hell could he come
home you come home and have him yell at
you for being and being controlling
towards you like where were you
I know it's a moment he was just I think
it was also like his way of like well
maybe he wanted to see me or like you
know it's so easy what a little of that
too yeah
so it's that's the other side of it it's
cute he missed you you gonna do huh and
it's also being able to recognize that
in the moment quickly instead of like
true really
so it's listen relationships are
cohabitating with another person what
whichever type of relationship you're in
I think is tricky because it's you're
you're sharing this space yeah and
everybody has rules about their space
and everybody's rules are different do
you think that really romantic
relationships are different than
friendships well usually you don't live
with your friends and what your
expectation is from your friends is is
different and you're always sort of
looking you're sort of I think secretly
angling to get something from your
partner and I also think once we flip it
sometimes and say you know what I'm just
gonna love you the best I can
what you end up getting back is so much
bigger than if you're angling mmm if you
just go like because like if Laird
decides one day like maybe he he wants
to go I I would be like wow I really
gave my best and then I would be like
good luck because that's all I can do
yeah and what happens is is I think when
we really try our best people usually
recognize that and they go it's pretty
good here yeah you know my girlfriends
and I were talking about it earlier this
year on a little girls trip and it
really came down to for us we were
talking about attachment non-attachment
like being detached from the outcome
with a friend totally detached from the
outcome Gabby if you're rude to me mean
to me you don't call me back you don't
follow through you you know you're not
contributing to the friendship by being
vulnerable sure
don't care if I'm not your friend
anymore yeah I'll go get another one
yeah and in a relationship you are
attached to the outcome you're like sure
so you pardon them along the way and you
want something from you want them to
meet the expectations that get to the
certain attached point out here of like
we're married forever we have a great
family we're perfect and there's this
just not this just the attachment
non-attachment is what we figured out is
like the problem because you're okay to
see a friend go because you don't like
you don't attach yourself to some
distant outcome with that friend it's
just here and now it's just here and now
but that's what it is every day for all
of us well you can choose that with a
partner but we I mean I victim to
thinking way ahead I'm a forward thinker
not a back thinker so if you asked me if
I would ever if I regret anything in my
past I really don't cuz I really do like
that is my answer like I'm total
butterfly effect I'm happy where I am
here today wouldn't change thing I also
don't spend any time thinking about that
yeah I'm always thinking forward so
that's my problem is I think you're
attached to the future and an outcome
and it makes it really hard for me to
operate in the present sometimes and
flow because I get attached to outcomes
okay but let's let's look at that really
quickly when you're driving a vehicle
you have to understand where you're
going to be very quickly very soon so it
makes perfect sense to sort of be
anticipating okay what's happening so I
think in one way it's about giving
yourself understanding that it makes a
lot of sense that you're that that is a
sort of feeling of a natural way for you
to be and I think you know when you when
you move through life and if you really
ask some questions and you start to kind
of dig deep on a lot of things which I
know you do already is you start to
realize how do i yes plan for the future
because you know life takes a level of
navigating you have to navigate
intention but how do I understand that
really not only am I not in control of
it I have been in a long relationship
and I have three daughters and I tell
you each day that I wake up I realize
I'm gonna earn it today like I earned
mine
my marriage today and that's really all
I can do because I don't know if Laird
and I are gonna be married in ten years
or in one year mm-hmm for whatever
reasons we're out there and so I would
get up and when I put my feet on the
floor I say okay I'm going to do my best
to earn it
and whatever happens happens and that
comes down to dating someone and
thinking of marrying them and and I'll
tell you what what's the heaviest of all
is children because you know I when they
hand you a baby you can make all kinds
of plans and you get a kid all of a
sudden you start watching them you're
like oh they're good at this and they're
talented at that and you can start
really looking and what you realize is
that you actually are not really in
charge of that you're just not really in
control of it so what you can do is to
keep them safe and love them and put and
expose them to things but let me tell
you when your kids do things that they
like that you hate like who are you and
you and it is the biggest lesson because
you go oh yes that's right you are not
me and we're separate and even though I
had this plan for you you have another
plan and so I think it's it's a level of
surrendering that is so uncomfortable
but once you get into it more and more I
think it opens up the way you can see
everything and you just kind of go oh
okay you know I can only impact my
outward life by my my own actions and
thoughts and feelings and really it's
thoughts right like you know that from
saying like oh I'm gonna train and I'm
gonna eat this because you're making
choices yeah and we can take those same
choices and say I'm this is I'm going to
choose this in a relationship or how I'm
going to react or things like that so
it's I think to be more in charge in
charge and to and to even get bigger
with it is to actually find the way to
kind of say okay I'll loosen up on the I
mean even metaphorically you hold on to
a wheel and make the car go where you
want it to go okay
the death grip my whole life right so
like yeah it makes a lot of sense even
when I retired that was what I said is I
had to learn the difference between
quitting and letting go because you just
I mean I qug n I'm hold on right you
just keep going and then my sister's
describe me and she's like you have
stamina for everything like you are a go
go go you don't tire ran I had to learn
the difference in quitting and letting
go not only from a verbage standpoint
but the way that that those words mmm
sunk in and felt for me right because if
someone talked about me being done
racing and I thought it was quitting
I'd be guarded I'd be I'd be offended at
times I'd feel insecure mm-hmm but I let
go I'm totally fine with that
yeah or how about they come up to you
and go oh so what are you doing now that
you're not racing yeah all that identity
right right and then it's like you
should just say this and that because
you don't have to go well I'm doing this
and then I'm traveling and then I have a
podcast and all that because now you're
chopped
you're having to explain to somebody oh
well I'm gonna reinforce this identity
right doesn't matter my friends who came
to some friends came to visit a couple
weeks ago and they own a company that
helps people you know helps people with
their business as a business owner from
the inside out and outside in so
finances but also then the personal
relationships and they just do a great
job of being really thorough about that
and so so it's it's hey where'd you say
I totally lost my shirt oh no we're just
talking about identity and like oh what
do you you know oh yes that's why I know
they're so they're so just an hour
you're hanging out yeah punch people in
the face when they talk to me like that
so they go to a party and they play this
game that when people ask him Oh what do
you do mm-hmm
and they look at you they go oh I I surf
I'd like to spend time with my daughter
and they go on they talk about all the
things they like to do but then they go
oh you want to know what we do for like
to make money that's different yeah and
it also sounds as crappy of a question
as it can be right and I think I think
that that's another thing of having many
iterations of a career where I'm at is
and even watching Laird Laird is what is
so over talented but
get really mainstream recognition till
he's in his mid-30s and it's realizing
like that's all made up and so if you're
doing stuff that you feel really good
about and you're around people that you
really dig and they love you that's what
you're doing and it isn't about like I'm
the fastest that I'm a race car and I'm
the only female I'm the first female
it's like that's just stuff that can
keep us from just fills TV time it's a
magazine article you know and like you
know and people have to realize like oh
the newest and the latest and the
greatest and the has-been and then the
comeback and then all this stuff that
they do to keep the stories going three
girls mmm how how do you how do you make
them understand that how do you make
them understand how do you you know you
grew up not having to be anything you
said right like you don't have you never
had to be something when you grow up
which is an amazing fundamental that
allows you so much space to be whoever
it is that you are which so many of us
just are who we are told to be who our
parents think we should be or what our
parents do so how do you like take those
fundamentals that are so good but hard
and like get your teenage kids to like
grasp that consistency you got to be it
and they'll watch you and they won't
believe you and they will do it very
different and then they'll I think it
starts to sink in and then they will
also do things differently than you do
and and that's okay too but trying to
figure out how to take the pressure off
of them is the hardest thing I have
because I'm always like thinking to your
point I was saying especially kind of
one of my daughters too or are different
they're not it doesn't seem to bother
them as much but one feels like this you
know pressure from inside her own self
not a message from Laird Nye of like I
have to do something but also that might
be what's driving her so I think it's
hard for her but the expectation is
trying just to remind her you're you
were us just being you and Laird is
enough to make a child think that they
have to do something I know I do feel
better compensate for that verbally know
because words mean nothing
it's just about showing them over and
over also as people like where do we
place value on so we don't place value
on like oh yeah hey you know got into
this school and yeah it's like it's like
hey work hard figure out who you are
what what kind of what turns you on and
and try to be a good friend and have
good friends and it like if you can sort
of accomplish those things because
everything takes hard work and so
getting them to understand the value of
hard work and and and also you know a
level of kindness to other people and
and and encourage them to simultaneously
know how to stand up for themselves I
think that that's important too it's
like hey you don't have to take people's
crap but as far as going out in the
world and being someone well what does
that mean I mean it's such a ridiculous
thing it's like hey listen Cesar's dead
Napoleon's dead
it's like Marilyn Monroe's dead and we
can just go through time and history and
talk about every most powerful important
person that there's ever been
they're not here Justin Bieber will be
more important to my 11 year old you
know then you know Roosevelt so at what
point what are we really talking about
it's just something that we do talk you
by ourselves and so let's really go back
into like Who am I and what I want to do
because that's really kind of the only I
think one of the only real things yeah
is it hard to be a parent oh my god it's
the heart that harder to hit playing
volleyball have too little that you did
oh yeah all day long I think why is it
you love them they love you yeah it's on
a family like what mate right and
volleyball like their people are their
crush you you know it's competitive yeah
well it doesn't matter to care is it do
you care more yeah okay you you care
we're way more and also it's your one
shot like if I lose a game I can go back
well like your kid one shot at that game
- yes but you sort of have this
different arc and it's it's just
different this is like hey I've got to
invest
time and energy and try to make good
decisions right now because that's gonna
get baked in there and then they're
gonna be this age but each season you
could start over
Kaleo the seat with the volleyball
season but but with kids they're not
going to forget when you lashed out or
they're not going to fry it when you
demonstrated something that was
counterintuitive to what you've been
saying or when actually to what's
interesting and I didn't realize this
until my kids were older is that also
what is also very hard about parenting
is that there will be things that happen
to them outside of your control that you
were protecting them from or whatever
and so you are dealing with outside
forces or situations that sure make it
more complicated sirs little girls will
come home and start to say new things
act a certain way and my sister will be
like she learned that from so-and-so at
school yeah you know little things when
they're a kid but surely as you get
older even more bigger things yeah or or
if they you know make choices that are
not good for themselves and you have to
ride that out with them and you try and
ride it out or do you try and fix it I
think the impulse is to want to fix it I
think when you when you really step back
and try to really look at what is
parenting which is to guide this person
to a place where they can manage their
own lives not control their lives
there's levels of it where you have to
ride it out because you've got to get
right knife involved you need to help
them but when it's a butter knife you
can just kind of let them figure it out
right like yeah a little are things yes
and sometimes they have to they have to
fall and it's hard to watch and I and
and and you have to also have belief in
the foundation that you've put in too so
when your children are small you have a
lot of control and so you can be with
them and love them and you know feed
them well into all the stuff and then as
they become independent there's stuff
sometimes they after watching Tommy like
you're like oh you wish it was just
honest okay
play it's just I think it's and it's
also I'll tell you what's really
uncomfortable like it would crack you
open like an egg is all of a sudden I
had someone point this out to me two
years ago you have a hammer I have a
hammer I use my hammer a lot I can
hammer down hammer through and then
she's like and now with that tool you're
gonna wash the windows and so what does
that mean that means you need a new tool
and you're like oh but that's so
uncomfortable my hammers work for 30
years I feel like you're telling my
story I keep going yes but so this is
one thing but because you love your
children so much you go you know what
and I would do it for my partner I'm
gonna take a look at that and I'm gonna
maybe be willing to go to areas of
myself and life that are very
uncomfortable for me because I would
like to develop a new tool so that I can
help this manage this for this child
because what you don't need to show them
is that you're perfect what you need to
show them is that you're willing to try
and you're also willing to try something
new and that was very uncomfortable it
really yeah you do this all the time I
hear like you've worked your whole life
by by pushing through like you guys
worked for you the tough has worked for
you but you don't have to do that
anymore
no and like I hear that and I'm like but
it works so good so good yeah and he's
like it doesn't serve you anymore no and
like my advice for like even this he's
like you realize you're gonna get so
much further if you put the hammer down
and you just listen to people yeah it's
like I feel like this is my therapy
because I'm such a talker I just got
shut up right now
well no it's listen we're all that's the
whole great thing about life right is
each leg day you could do something
differently and new and and you could
then string days of that together and
look back like a year or two and be like
wow I do that a lot better now and that
is growth - mm-hmm so I think it's it's
good but it's also kind of going like oh
yeah I I don't really like this or even
feeling disappointed as a parent there's
moments where you go well I thought if I
did all the right things and I I kept a
place then you know
safe and clean and they I provided them
with education and love and you know
Laird and I don't beat the hell out of
each other and like all these things
that like you wouldn't be you wouldn't
have to deal with certain things or
certain things wouldn't have to come
upon your children and you realize
that's just not the case and so you have
choices to make and that's why I can
remember thinking oh I now I know why
parents say well that's how we do it in
this house and that's the way it is
final because in certain ways that's
easier because then you don't have to
look at yourself and be like oh you know
because we all have our own crap still
layered in there no matter how much
we've served worked on it so we have go
twos that are safe yeah and easy
yep familiar and they've worked yeah
like they overall be overall so I want
to talk about this concept of having it
all because I have my I have my
perspective okay having it all yeah I
think you can you culture of like oh
yeah everything everything's perfect
let's have it be a strong woman have a
family be really that ridiculous and I
think it's interesting you know we
always say like you never asked men what
if a guy goes to work and you're like oh
but you didn't get to see the kids at
school right I think it's an unfair and
I say this on the women's side meaning
why is it like men can't have it all why
do we think we can have it all like we
teach a kid like okay we're at the
birthday party there's a cupcake and ice
cream so you can't have both so make a
choice right like with this is stuff
that we've learned very early I think
you can have it all but not all at the
same time so I think you can have
different chapters of your life
experiencing different things but the
idea of like well I should be able to
have it all it's like okay well let's
grow up and be adults and realized that
that is not really practical and so the
fact that if a woman is working and she
decides she wants to have a kid puts her
at a disadvantage biologically and
emotionally if they want to make that
into a cultural conversation about it
not being fair I think is ridiculous
because part of its biology layered
can't have the baby layer can't nurse
the baby
by the way you couldn't have ripped me
out of my house anyway
hey you're the CEO and here's your zeros
and you're in charge I'd be like ya know
right now this is what I'm doing and
that was my choice and by the way there
are women who don't have that luxury
like they have to go back to work
because they have to feed their family
that's what's happening and you know
what keep the roof over their head good
on them and let's support them but the
problem is is when we also try to
compare or align that with the men's
experience do I think our culture could
do a better job of supporting new moms
working new moms absolutely like if you
go to Scandinavian countries it's like
hey this much time for the mom even the
dad however what we say in the u.s. is
hey this is a competitive environment
you can be anything you want to be but
guess what it's sort of every man for
himself so that doesn't make it right
but it's set up all the way around to be
like that so now you have a mom who's a
working mom and a new mom and the
culture pretty much does the same thing
to her so will she lose the promotion
possibly to her male counterpart because
he can work 12 hours and she has to she
can't possibly who do you think that's
fair I don't know what that means
what if she's better at her job but she
can't do it and he because she knows too
much children yeah cuz she of course
it's not fair but like I have said to my
kids if you want fair go to the
fairground like is it fair that I could
hit a white ball and get paid some weird
amount of money compared to somebody who
has to work construction bust their ass
for 14 hours it's ridiculous there's
unfair all around so I think it's about
understanding what you want to manage
what you want and how do you do that and
understand where the pitfalls are going
to be in where it's unfair and crappy
mm-hm and if you want the kids then you
also get the advantage of being able to
have that super deep connection you get
it right you you're having the baby
yourself it's coming out of your body
you get to be home with it you get to
you get to have that connection you get
to you know inspire them make a little
mini amazing human and there's a lot of
Manta sizing this whole positive
experience as opposed
- like grinding it out at work I know
buddy that you look at the two sides of
it and say like you know and you also
have the choice right if you don't want
I think you want the promotion I think
it's by all your choices I think it's a
very viable thing for a woman to say you
know what I think what's gonna make me
feel good mm-hmm is to crush it at work
and guess what she will and she could
become the boss and will become the boss
and if she says maybe I'd like to
explore being you know I I feel like I'd
like to express myself in motherhood and
by the way none is better than the other
I always say to people I will never
romanticize marriage or Parenthood it's
really an individual choice and it's
really to know yourself and what's gonna
turn you on at the end of your life you
go you know what I did it my way I did
it the way that made me feel good
but I think the better question is not
is it fair it's tough is it tough it is
tough and I think for women too it's
like how do you keep your thread of your
career going and try to have children
and that is a really it will be the
ongoing question forever and ever
because it's hard because also being a
mother right is sort of still especially
when they're young there's a stillness
and even like you ever see a dog give
birth and then like the puppy's and like
you know she lays there and it's like oh
god here they come
there's even like you know when you
first have a kid it's like okay and if
you think like you can be exactly the
way you were you know before you had a
kid can you go back absolutely but in
these pockets it is so still yeah I mean
like you almost want to like you know
there's days where you're the least
motivated they'd still be bored I mean
it's Matt it's so magical but you're
just like okay here I am that's your
test then and the world is moving ahead
without me you know right that
insecurity shows like I'm not
accomplishing anything right as I'm sure
what I'd be thinking about doing
anything I'm so worthless right now wait
oh wait this baby will die without me
that's not super worthless done well and
it's when it goes by they're just like
it's so quick so I think it's just
understanding what you can handle and
what you want yeah but to you know say
that it because because by the way I
wouldn't I even if let's say Laird
couldn't nurse I wouldn't want him to I
would want to be the one mm-hmm
I want to talk about this just because I
feel like we can relate to each other on
it and I think this would be an
interesting conversation but you know
you have girls growing up you don't know
what they're gonna do one of them is in
sports
mm-hmm and look you were eroded down you
were a Nikes first spokeswoman now a
magazine named you top five beautiful
women in the world you've modeled you've
got endorsements like you've been the
face of things so being a woman and
using looks like that is something that
always comes up in my world as far as
you know less now because I'm not in
sports anymore but man that was a thing
for a while and so when racecar driving
too that's even more exact right to
contract contrast and even more so like
what's your feelings on all that like
what would you what would you how would
you how would you use what you've
learned to help your girls have an
understanding for how to be strong and
what it is that they're comfortable with
yes we can not worry about what people
say cuz there's so much things so much
is said about you know sexuality and
like women just aren't able to be sexual
without it being a problem oh yeah oh or
pretty without it being a problem you
lose you're using your looks like yeah
I've long hair well I don't anymore but
yeah um okay well that's it it probably
with well for me it was a it's a complex
in a different way because so when I was
coming up and then I was went to college
to play volleyball then I started
modeling legitimately and it created an
independent for me I gave up my college
scholarship to play ball that I was and
I paid to play at school because I was
an independent person I had I wasn't
relying on my parents so I took it as a
job basically so then when I got into
professional sports my thing was I'm
gonna train really hard
I'm gonna be a really good teammate you
know I'm gonna be very professional and
I'm very that mean you didn't do then
well it also meant that I professional
just meaning like if I lost and just got
my ass kicked and got off the court and
people 50 people are standing there or
you know to do whatever sign something
and be gracious I would that's part of
being professional right and yeah well I
mean I think also you have to realize I
was on a on a very small platform so I
call it the song and dance so I was
looking at my sports platform and going
like I see very clearly all the
limitations here and so if playing a
card that I have in my deck that I have
nothing to do with I I didn't work for
that I just for whatever reason and I do
it tastefully and correctly to the best
to a place that I feel comfortable with
then it will provide more opportunity
for me
and it will bring more attention to my
sport and in that order by the way I'm
not going to be us and say well for my
sport more opportunity for me and for my
sport I'm comfortable doing that as long
as the other stuff was in order and it
always was I always trained hard
I was always straight ahead I always did
the extra and people can say it's not
fair okay it's not I totally own it and
I played with girls who could jump you
know eight inches higher than me did
they not you know it's like is that not
fair because they were burned with born
with that right so I think it was but
listen also I never and certainly as I
got older I didn't shy away from what it
is I knew what it was and I knew exactly
just kind of how far to push it and and
I thought as long as I was showing up
and working really hard I felt
comfortable managing that but yes it was
oh yeah people had some dialog for me
for sure yeah and that's okay doing the
work for the job is number one of course
because you know you've earned
then right you feel like you've earned
it more so when you're like look I'm
working really hard like I'm putting an
effort I mean it should be easy if it's
your passion which you know volleyball
was yours and racing was mine but but
that's part of it that way when someone
says something negative then you can't
feel it you don't feel Baxter like I
just did everything I could like I know
I'm working my butt off and then you
have no reason to feel guilty or
insecure because you know you've done
everything that you possibly can and you
know it's a powerful place to be in to
do that
to be confident in your efforts yeah so
that whatever happens afterwards yeah
but look there's a pros and cons for all
of it and one in 23 I it was hard like
when I was 22 you were leading away like
you'll it led the way on a woman being
able to be beautiful and an athlete I
was there at the right time let's just
say that there was other athletes who
sort of tilled the ground for me so when
my generation came it was ready to roll
so I think but at 23 I was like oh you
know staying in your comfort zone is the
critical element I think yes I always
did that now I'm not saying that I have
the same comfort zone as you or correct
or him like I'm not saying they're the
same but it's mine there's plenty of
things I said no - yeah especially in my
godaddy days there was plenty of stuff I
said no - sure I mean I was given
concepts for Super Bowl commercials and
like I think that's a good one yeah I'm
not really comfortable with that and
there weren't - to be in charge of it
yeah I didn't do things that I wasn't
comfortable but I have a large comfort
zone yeah I have I felt yes and I think
also with my size and everything I had a
different relationship with just you
know you're playing volleyball and you
know bait it's just you know on and on
like bathing suits and stuff like that
but I think that that that you know the
image stuff is tricky right because that
we live in a world where so much image
right there's so much facade out there
and social media is like the you know is
a wonder can be a wonderful platform but
it can also be extremely dangerous and
has developed so many insecurities and I
think that it's really led women to
maybe men - of course but I feel like
it's more of a fee
the comparison comparison is the thief
of joy yeah but to you know think about
you know what it is that's going to
attract a guy let's say and I loved when
I was reading some information about you
there was a wonderful wonderful bit of
information that I read that I thought
yes how do we teach girls that this is
what's important and I'm gonna read it
Laird said this is about meeting you and
about you know the first time you guys
met and then what attracted him to you
and he said ultimately it wasn't love at
first sight it was an infatuation after
first conversation my intrigue of Gabbi
was brought to life after realizing how
smart she was and we think that we're
supposed to go out there and put this
beauty filter on and that's what we're
gonna get a guy from yeah and you know
how do we like how do we how do we build
strong independent ambitious fit I'm
gonna say pretty because if you're
confident and you're fit and you take
care of yourself and you treat yourself
with respect it's gonna show your heart
you are you're gonna be it's just gonna
happen it's gonna be a byproduct giving
a [ __ ] about yourself that's right
which then it makes you give a [ __ ]
about other people because we treat
people how we treat ourselves how do we
build how do we build these people even
guys too but I think it's a little bit
more of a vulnerability for girls I
think first of all it does start with
our moms and the other thing I tell my
girls is develop a skill something
you're in charge of because if you like
me or don't like me or you think I'm
attractive or not I can't control that
but if I have a skill that I'm working
on and all of a sudden I go to practice
and I'm a little bit better because I
practice also the power that we get when
we when we're good at something or we
like something right we're passionate
about something so I always tell my
girls that it has to start there and and
you know certainly be pretty is is bonus
but you know I read this one said if if
beauty is your currency then starting
you know then you get poorer each day
right
and so you think like it longer
hopefully like I you know I I'll be 50
next year hopefully the longer I'm
around the more the more I can continue
to contribute yeah but I have to do that
by continuing to develop myself as a as
a thinking person not just a woman and
not how's my butt look because not only
are there millions of those and there
are and it's it's a it's a really tough
treadmill to be on if you're like to
look good and my skinny is my weight and
on my pretty how's my skin it's like
it's just it's it's really it's really
tough so I think it's a if your mom's to
be an example even like you putting out
that image out there about like hey I'll
race with the boys and all this stuff
these things are impactful but it's -
but what's hard and I've talked about
this a little bit is now you add social
media which actually reinforces that
pretty is good enough because it's like
she gets more followers and more likes
and then the drop off that cliff is
pretty ugly so if you do that long
enough and then you didn't spend that
time investing in yourself right and
doing that work because it is where side
of yourself for validation and it's
gonna go away
yeah either you're gonna go away or
they're gonna go fix everything
temporary yes and I think what's
interesting about experience laird and I
talk about this a lot is like you just
can't fake that you have to lay down the
work and so when people do that I think
their life then their currency it's like
yeah of course when you're 13 to 30 you
know and you're at your height of
biological signaling if you're sort of
in a Cano conventional life your path is
certainly different but it's like yeah
that should be more of the story because
you are going like hey I'm here to make
babies like people forget the biology
about it right so I understand that it's
more important but even beyond that then
you serve go OK simultaneously to that
Who am i developing as a person and what
skills am i developing so I'm
contributing beyond like you know how do
I look and then as you get older I think
it becomes also how am I going to
support the world that I've created so
is it my family and my friends and if
I'm in a community and if I have longer
arms fine and also how am I going to
continue to make to know how to make
myself feel good because if you don't
know how to do that and then you start
getting older it is really tough I think
it could be really tough and then also
you you keep your power it just shifts
so your power shifts from just being
youthful and all these things to now
you've got life's experience maybe you
know I always joke I'm like it doesn't
matter if I have fine lines because I'm
someone's boss you know it's like
doesn't really matter you know they
won't have sex with me because that's
not where I'm at right now
but I think it's it's sort of just
getting but no twelve or thirteen year
old can really think about that stuff
yeah so ultimately you have to have
examples out there and you have to model
it and beyond that you just do like a
lot of like you I mean yeah if it was a
path was easy and laid out and predicted
you know if we just knew all the answers
it wouldn't be fun it wouldn't be
wouldn't grow it wouldn't be an
adventure right because look when the
things when the [ __ ] hits the fan that's
where you're making memories right you
don't remember whenever you're not super
smooth you're just like it was nice oh
yeah right so go ahead and like just you
know have a goal you know I think this
is a morbid thing to do but maybe this
would be an interesting concept that's
whatever age was appropriate but I think
I'd told you the other day at work out
but I wrote my obituary yeah what's
heavy I wrote how I wanted to be
remembered yeah and maybe that would be
for me it was important because it
showed me something I needed to work on
but maybe that's something that you
could sort of re-evaluate and and and
redo on a random on a regular basis I'm
not saying like every day or every week
or every month but not even maybe not
even every year but every couple of
years you rebase line and go how do I
want to be remembered because it's gonna
have all been changed and that's totally
fine too and I think that's also
something that people that is fine to
understand is that your life won't just
be the same and
not gonna be it's not gonna be linear
you're not gonna do one thing your whole
life and in fact you should do as many
things as you possibly can that fill
your soul like I couldn't agree more and
and I think what is interesting two
things I think also start to happen is
as I you have a little more experiences
certain things become so clear and so
simple and then you start to realize how
much you just don't know easily right
some of it comes easily yeah so you go
like wow this is exciting it's it's all
very simple I don't waste my time in a
lot of emotional upheaval if I could
something is going to be happening and
drama I'm out of it before I ever got
into it and simultaneously it's like
opening one door and seeing a hundred
more doors and going oh yeah I don't
really know anything and then those two
things living comfortably side by side
and also you know again like you said
being willing to could just kind of look
at it and go oh you know what I might
need to make a change so I think it's an
ongoing the dance of life and and I also
believe if we have people that we really
are excited about or that we're excited
about around us that really are giving
us love and we are taking care of
ourselves that that's probably a pretty
good place to start find good people and
take care of yourself yeah and how
people tell you the truth will take care
of others then absolutely good thanks
Gabby this is fun thank you thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today I hope you enjoyed
it and also thank you so much Trevor
hall for the awesome music if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the subscribe
button